hello everyone i'm alana and today we
are talking about dying light 2 which i
was able to play early uh like eight
weeks ago i'm very late to making this
video um because i recently moved and
something
i had hardware issues and i was unable
to to render at all the like six hours
of footage that was all on one file that
i had from the dynaline 2 event whatever
that has now been fixed i did get to
play the game only and i'm allowed to
talk about everything that i played
which is wonderful all of the gameplay
you're seeing today is actually from the
october build i believe some people
might have more recent gameplay so the
game probably does look significantly
better than this now of course so i took
a bunch of questions from you guys on
instagram and on youtube and now i'm
going to answer them all about dying
light 2. dabiel said i remember you
saying that games are going to start
getting a lot more ambitious or
something of the sort and that dying
light 2 is the first of them with this
all changing world does this still seem
to be the case so if you've been
following me for a while um i have often
spoken about my interest in dying light
2 because it seemed to be one of the
first games that is taking this
uh change to narrative that i suspect a
lot of games are going to do going
forward um that ken levine is attempting
to do with the game that he's making
right now is the example that i bring up
most often he's had a gdc talk about it
uh where
in exchange for having set pieces uh
which is what we call like
you know a big epic cinematic structured
moment in a game things are instead very
much personalized to individual players
dying light 2 does a little bit of this
though not as much as i had originally
hoped or perhaps fantasized that it
would i don't think they ever promised
what i was hoping that they would do
which is essentially like you know if
you do a quest for one person then uh
the world changes in a certain way and
and it feels like an actual authentic
butterfly effect um again very much like
what ken levine is trying to do in dying
light to the impact that you have is um
when you overtake
uh what is effectively this game's
versions of like the water tower in a
lot of instances you can choose who you
are claiming it for which faction you
are claiming it for and that will have a
physical impact on the world uh
surrounding that area so say you choose
one faction there will be more street
level traps for the zombies you choose
another faction there will be another
benefit for you um so
yes it it it does change the world in in
a way that i feel like probably a lot of
games don't do and it is actually pretty
cool
but it's also very specific and um very
structured you know exactly what you're
changing i will say that the world also
feels very different to the first game
like is in the actual look of the world
in the world design in a pretty
impressive way what they
said that they were going for was like
the world had kind of fallen back into a
sort of medieval era 20 years after this
outbreak
and the central hub of um most of where
the chunks of game that i got to play
was
the bazaar which is in the middle of um
this one particular area is literally a
church but i think it feels a lot more
rich in identity it feels like its own
distinct game where the original dying
light maybe felt like it could have been
any city just kind of in shambles
dying light 2 has a very distinct visual
style and the world feels very distinct
and again because that's customizable it
can become more distinct as you play the
other thing which they have also spoken
about but i think that they nailed
visually is the difference between the
rooftops and the streets so sometimes
the rooftops will have like virtually
little parks on the rooftops like
water towers with with lush green little
mini forests up there
and then the street level uh because
nobody really goes down there anymore
because you are likely to die because
that's where the zombies are is like
baron wasteland-esque it can be very
brown and bleak and and very battered so
there's definitely a lot of variety in
that as well i just yeah i feel like
that was the thing that i think that i
was the most um impressed by and the
thing that felt like such a big
evolution from the first game is a very
distinct
purposeful style
um
aesthetically that also obviously ties
into the gameplay of the parkour and in
one of the later sections it goes beyond
parkour it's it's uh ziplines pulleys
paraglider with these little like air
vents that as you fly over them will
shoot you up so that you can get more
length from your glide so yeah the world
is so clearly designed with gameplay in
mind which is something that i'm always
very impressed by that is some very good
level design which can be harder to do
in something that feels a little bit
open world and it is open while there's
just multiple different open worlds
effectively um the section with all
those air vents
was sort of more of a city called the
central hub i believe that had um
you know skyscrapers so
very distinct look between the two areas
but yeah a consistent style double d
said they said the infected wouldn't be
outside in daylight as someone used to
play mainly the day in dl1 i feel like
i'm gonna miss messing with them even if
humans are cool to fight still not the
same right so you still can see infected
outside during the day there are
effectively two games in one the daytime
is for humans the night time is for the
infected and it means that you have to
approach each of these times with a
different strategy potentially with
different equipment with different
approaches to literally where you are
going to go if you're gonna go indoors
um during the day they're gonna be
infected like
all crammed up in there loads of them
whereas i feel like at night time
they're a little bit more spread out
though they are more vicious so it
definitely feels a little bit different
from the first dying light but yeah it
feels like an evolution um it is it is
two games uh that you have to think
about and approach differently at
different times and that is something
that i liked about it it is humans that
you are to be afraid of during the day
which i feel like is the same in the
first dying light i remember towards the
end of that game finding the humans
really hard to fight
yeah it's a real focus on the human
element during the day there's a good
momentum of like you wanting to get
between these places and understanding
why these certain people are mad at you
or if somebody's betrayed you or
whatever else which of course happens
quite a bit but yeah you can definitely
get caught up with with humans being
jerks during the day the biggest
difference between the day night cycles
is that there is more of a reason to
explore at night now um so a lot of
players
seemingly just didn't really engage with
the night time at all um the first time
around i think that i yeah i pro i think
that i avoided it at all costs actually
if i remember correctly it would do it
occasionally maybe there was a certain
mission where i had to but um in this
game they've incentivized different
things if you explore at nighttime you
can of course go to a bed and sleep if
you want to too but um
there are reasons to be out at night to
experience
the the two different styles of gameplay
that exist based on the time of day the
main one being uh you know i said the
interiors are really full uh during the
day because zombies are trying to avoid
the the light though zombies coming out
at night means that those interiors are
more explorable at night time so yes
you're probably still going to see some
zombies inside of
a certain building um you're almost
definitely going to die going into a lot
of them during the day at night time you
can actually go in there and loot them
and see what's in there ps3 gaming
scotland said what makes dynalite 2
stand out compared with the similar
zombie games the thing that stands out
about dying light 2 to me is um the free
running obviously is a huge part of it
but i think also the combat um there are
no guns this time around whatsoever it
is up close and personal and i feel like
a lot of zombie games are like a little
bit too scared to do that sometimes but
yeah the free running is a big thing it
feels so good in dying so so so so many
animations um the only thing that i
didn't like about it and this is
actually my number one least favorite
thing
about my time playing dying light 2 is
that i feel like some of the abilities
uh were locked behind upgrades that
should have been available from the
start the first game did this a little
bit i think the second game does it more
basically um my criticism there would be
that some
abilities concerning free running um
like wall running
are locked you need to unlock them and
that's something that i feel like if you
had from the start would make the game
so much
more enjoyable from
moment one there were just some things
that i feel like they should have
unlocked from the beginning that they
didn't that you had to put points
towards and you had to work towards
where
it just makes the the whole experience
of running through the city a little bit
less fun
um and i get like specializing and
upgrading on some of those things but
there are just certain core abilities
that i really wish you had
from the very very beginning
because they would just make it better
from the very very beginning essentially
and i think that's probably like in part
to the game's credit as well but that
that free running is so freaking cool
that when you don't get to just do all
of it straight away you're like come on
just give me a little bit more um but
that's something that i i feel like most
people will agree on it seems like
something that so clearly
would be cooler if you could do all of
it at once if there's any major
difference in parkour i'll be honest i
haven't played dying like the first one
since it came out so it's hard to say
exactly but i felt like the jumping
feels like a little bit um
kind of lighter maybe
i feel like you can jump further and uh
that depends on how much momentum you've
built up of course there's no way to
sprint so you just kind of have to like
run and jump and run and jump to to gain
speed which is always fun until you get
blocked by something because you don't
have a skill which
such a shame there is of course also a
combat skill tree which i imagine
kind of expands on this even more um but
i didn't get super deep into that i know
that they said that they
sort of had a goal where they wanted to
make sure that you weren't just doing
your parkour and then stopping and
hitting some enemies in the face they're
trying to like really integrate the two
of them and i feel like i had unlocked a
couple of abilities um that lent into
that nicely
but
not enough to accurately say if i feel
like they accomplished what they were
going for there i frankly really love
bows in games uh or silent stealth
weapons so it i guess
for me in some cases did feel like two
separate
games but i i hope and and they did say
that they intended to as you unlock more
combat abilities that they really pair
together a little bit more smoothly
vince de monkey said how's the writing
in this game is it a compelling story if
i haven't played the first game can i
just jump into this one um the writing
in this game is probably the thing that
surprised me the most and by that i
basically mean um it feels like a
fallout game it sort of feels like an
obsidian game
it's very um
you go up to an individual person and
they generally have a very quirky kind
of character they're all very distinct
and they will uh with dialogue options
you know give you
context if you would like it or give you
a quest and you go on your merry way it
basically feels a lot more like an rpg
than the first game did and i think that
that probably ties pretty directly into
the um news articles recently concerning
the play time uh where it came out
because they tweeted i guess uh
they came out with it that uh it would
take you 500 hours to finish the full
game when i asked the dev said that it
would only take 20 hours to finish the
main campaign which seems pretty
reasonable to me i feel like even the
first dying light i don't remember how
long it took me to finish but it was
lengthy enough but i would think that
the um
500 hours comes from you know 100
completing the map finding everything
and also from the side quests being a
lot beefier and the game as as a whole
just being a lot more rpg like
across the board it's a big map um very
very vertical actually is one thing that
uh they've definitely improved upon from
the first game it's a really really
vertical map basically with a whole
bunch of characters for you to talk to
quests for you to get context for you to
learn again it's almost like you
combined something a lot more fallout
with dying light uh and i do want to be
clear that that i liked that i found
that pretty fun but that does not
take away
from the
dying light of it all it is still very
uh focused on the free running or
parkour and what i would describe is
like very brutal in your face
kind of vicious
combat some of the narrative choices
definitely do seem dramatic um and i was
definitely interested in the story and
and the relationships and the characters
and and what was going on with them yeah
i really want to play more of it where
the story is concerned i never knew if i
was really making the right choice you
know i had an option to like abandon
someone or go help someone and i didn't
i didn't know what to do it was hard to
make some of those decisions which i
don't feel like a lot of games
necessarily nail especially not ones
that aren't intending to be like
full-fledged rpgs i mean it is very
rpg-esque again way more than the first
one manchester says what is the main
character like um
pretty standard
pretty standard main character type i
think his performance is fantastic uh
the actor was there at the event and and
he has also been in the dying to know um
videos and i thought his performance was
really really good
but i don't think that aiden is supposed
to be like the selling point of the
world the focal point of the world a lot
of the other characters around you are
kind of a lot crazier bordering on like
some of them being you know unrealistic
very much cartoonish um in ways that are
fun though like i'm glad that they're
that way it makes it more interesting
and kind of suits people you know going
nuts during the events of a zombie
apocalypse i can understand that
happening but yeah i would say he's um
he's not an unusual hero type he is
brave and compassionate and empathetic
and yeah he's definitely likable jujum
chong said how is the co-op game play in
the game is the so-called aspect like in
the first game there is co-op i did not
get to try it um for context i played on
pc at an event so i don't even
necessarily know the hardware of the pc
that i played on that was all up to them
up to techland but there is four player
co-op it just requires one player to
host and i think that is probably
because of um those city changing
aspects
that uh i spoke about earlier everyone's
cities should in theory look a fair bit
different based on the city alignment is
what they actually call the term uh
based on which faction they've decided
to allocate resources to at what time
and what part of the city um so you
couldn't all exist in the same world
because all of your worlds will look
different which is definitely a very
cool thing about it and the change that
i like the most uh it's neat i did
always choose the same faction every
single time um and this is like probably
uh a thing that i found to be a little
bit at odds with itself is that no
matter the narrative decision that might
make sense in that moment um you know
there's there's one part where maybe
you're confronted with a certain faction
and you have the opportunity to help
them or not and i would go with whatever
would help me mechanically rather than
what i believed was the right thing to
do with that particular story be and i
don't necessarily feel like i do that
in other rpg
lights and in dying light 2 i feel like
i did do that
because the parkour is
so much better if you lean into it in a
particular way so i was choosing to
align with the faction that would um
help my playstyle where the free running
and the combat were concerned and so it
meant that i was betraying people i
didn't necessarily want to sometimes
which is not something that i loved but
i do love that the city changes
according to to what you want to do so i
was really catering it to the way that i
liked to
get around
plenty of that was paragliding if i
could which is super cool
but yes if you are helping one faction
more than another faction one faction
might give you certain parkour routes
another one might give you crafting
stations or whatever else um your city's
gonna look really different so one
person is required to host in their city
the way they built their city
essentially hey potter said how do you
feel about the delays
same way i feel about all delays
excellent um games should always be
delayed if they need to it is way better
than releasing a broken game 100 of the
time stop telling people not to delay
games please
and then complaining when they have bugs
and i will say uh dying light 2
definitely did have some bugs the
biggest ones that i had are the worst
ones were probably that i would get
stuck inside of like scaffolding
sometimes while playing the parkour
which could be very frustrating um in a
game where
sometimes there was no other way out
than to just kind of wait for the
zombies to kill me so certainly an issue
but it's so hard to speak about bugs in
a preview build
when
you kind of don't know what is going to
be there and what isn't going to be
there on release sometimes preview
builds can have less bugs and final
releases
most of the time they have a lot more j
or melon said is it as terrifying as the
first they add more scary is that even
possible i never found the first game to
be too scary just tense in some moments
and i would say i felt the same way
about this
there were a couple of boss fights that
i was definitely worried about yeah
definitely some tension in you feeling
like you're fragile and you're going to
die and you're going to run out of
resources and you need to kind of manage
that stuff almost in an original dead
rising kind of way it's like worried
about the time of when things are
getting done and how you're going to get
them done but i don't feel like i found
it
tremendously scary i will say some of
the sound design
very creepy luke raven said love the
first game does the trailer live up to
the hype um yeah i mean i really enjoyed
my time playing it i'm very much
still looking forward to it looking
forward to it more after having played
it and from the trailers you do get a
really good glimpse at again that that
brutal visceral gory like
upfront in your face confronting combat
and they nail that feel so well it is
like the combat is tense man
you feel like you're part of it almost
because it's just so up close and
personal and just like rugged and really
really enjoyed it and yeah they're free
running you know they've spoken in
marketing about how many more animations
they have and it really really shows
it's
it's very impressive and just very fluid
like they've taken clearly some things
from assassin's creed certain like ways
of moving around the city and bridges
between things and stuff like that that
make it
you know fluid
a lot of the questions that i have left
over here
are actually um already things that
they've uh answered mostly in their
their uh
what is it dying to know um dying like
two clips so i recommend going to check
those out if you want more more info um
because i've actually already covered
most of those on the channel here as
well so i kind of i don't want to repeat
them too much so a lot of them are
things they have already spoken about
publicly like people asking for
different enemy types different zombie
types they've detailed that at way
better length than i could i think the
biggest change in terms of new zombies
um for the gameplay the most noticeable
one was probably the howlers howlers if
they spot you will let all of the horde
know exactly where you are so you will
either have to run away or or hide uh
from them to get them to stop pursuing
you with a thing called an actual chase
meter it uh
the closest way to describe it is that
it operates like uh stars and gta 5 do
and that is pretty much it um i
definitely really enjoyed playing the
game i am excited to play more of it i'm
definitely going to play more when it
comes out of course but i do really feel
like i only scratched the surface and i
don't
know exactly where the story's going to
go i didn't touch many side quests at
all um mostly played main story content
and i also didn't do a tremendous amount
of exploring because i was really just
getting through
the the chunk of the build that i could
in the time that i had actually kind of
slowly i felt like i saved it for a fair
amount of stuff but yeah the game
launches super soon huge thanks to
tecline for giving me early access and i
also of course want to give the
disclosure for anyone who doesn't know
how preview builds work that this is a
preview build which means that it is not
the game necessarily everything that
i've said is subject to change preview
builds have to be like tailor-made for
people to preview so i i can't guarantee
any of the things that i've said are
still in the final build of the game but
i did really enjoy it let me know if you
have any more questions that i might be
able to answer and i look forward to
playing more of the game very soon of
course we'll have more content on the
channel i loved the first game and um
yeah i think i'm gonna really like this
one too i'm alana i'll see you guys next
time